Flug Lufthansa 1152
im Landeanflug auf Palma de Mallorca:
Die Balearen-Insel ist
nach monatelangen
Corona-Beschränkungen
zu einem Traumziel
deutscher Urlauber geworden.
Wegen der großen Nachfrage ist
auf dem zweistündigen Flug
eine Boeing 747 unterwegs,
der Jumbo fliegt normalerweise
nur Langstrecken-Ziele
in Asien oder in Nordamerika an.
Flugkapitän Richard Weidlin prüft in Palma
Triebwerke und Fahrwerk auf Schäden.
Das ist ein ganz, ganz tolles Gefühl.
Die Pandemie hat so lange angedauert.
Wir hatten viele Piloten,
die in Kurzarbeit waren,
die sind teilweise bis zu anderthalb Jahre
nicht geflogen.
Wir freuen uns alle,
dass wir wieder unterwegs sein können.
Dann kommen die Passagiere
für den Rückflug nach Frankfurt an Bord.
Co-Pilot Felix Ebinger bereitet den Start vor.
Auf den Blick auf malerische Küsten
musste er anderthalb Jahre verzichten.
Wegen der Pandemie
wurden Piloten kaum gebraucht.
Ich hatte jetzt durch Corona
zwangsläufig ‘ne Pause
in Kurzarbeit von 15 Monaten,
was 'ne sehr, sehr lange Zeit ist.
So lange war ich noch nie
aus der Fliegerei raus.
Das ist ein ganz besonderes Gefühl,
wieder an Bord zu sein.
Sein erster Flug nach der Zwangspause
findet quasi unter Aufsicht statt.
Schulungs-Kapitän
Richard Weidlin überprüft,
ob noch alle Handgriffe sitzen –
auch wenn der Co-Pilot
bereits seit 17 Jahren fliegt.
In dem Moment, wo ich hier sitze
und meine Funktion ausübe,
muss die selbe Qualität und Sicherheit
gewährleistet sein
wie vor den 15 Monaten Pause,
Corona hin oder her.
Auch für die Flugbegleiterinnen
hinten in der Maschine
hat die Pandemie einiges verändert.
Deutschlands größte Airline hat Touristen
als neue Zielgruppe entdeckt.
Weil Geschäftsreisen durch
Videokonferenzen seltener geworden sind,
sollen Urlauber jetzt den Umsatz sichern –
und die Arbeitsplätze.
Auf den touristischen Zielen die Leute sind
natürlich voller Vorfreude.
Viele fliegen vielleicht
ein-, zweimal im Jahr nur,
haben andere Fragen.
Manche haben natürlich auch Flugangst.
Co-Pilot Felix Ebinger hat ein paar Tage
zuvor die Landung in Frankfurt durchgespielt
– im Simulator.
Hier musste der erfahrene Pilot
unter den strengen Augen eines Controllers
gefährliche Situationen meistern.
Erst danach darf er wieder
Passagiere befördern.
Das funktioniert erstaunlich gut.
Man setzt sich da hin und es ist da.
Trotzdem ist es gut,
erstmal im Simulator das zu üben.
Im „richtigen“ Flugzeug von Mallorca
sind Felix Ebinger und Schulungs-Kapitän
Richard Weidlin wieder in Frankfurt gelandet.
In zwei Tagen schon steht
der nächste Flug auf dem Dienstplan –
in die USA.